i hardly hardly find it uh
necessary to restate it but we have a
100
policy against doping they've just kind
of made a mockery of the system they're
abusing athletes
and it's business as usual
i think it's just another provocation
that the west has orchestrated against
our country
they are meddling in sports with their
dirty hands and dirty minds
at the heart of it is a young
athlete who's potentially being abused
at the hands of the russia state or
sports system they should have been
suspended in rio they should have been
suspended in pyeongchang and they should
have been suspended suspended in china
we've seen this story before and it's
finally time to wake up and do something
about it russian figure skater camilla
valeeva tested positive for a banned
substance just weeks before performing
this week in beijing heart medication
that can increase endurance was found in
the 15 year sample on christmas day of
last year
the russian anti-doping agency at first
suspended valieva but then lifted that
suspension and allowed her to compete
this week in beijing the international
olympic committee is trying to reverse
that decision by appealing to the
international court of arbitration for
sport
now the news has stunned olympic
athletes even more so because the
positive test result was first made
public after balayeva competed on monday
here's more now from dw's olympics
correspondent jonathan crane
well after days of speculation we do now
know that camilla valeeva is indeed the
athlete that tested positive for a
banned substance and is the center of
this legal dispute that has delayed the
medal ceremony for the team competition
in figure skating but we're still none
the wiser as to whether she will be able
to compete in her individual event next
week now the banned substance valia
tested positive for is typically used to
treat heart problems but it can also be
used to boost blood flow in the body the
course of arbitration for sport here in
beijing has an ad hoc panel it will now
arrange an urgent hearing to look at the
case it has to be urgent because that
individual competition takes place in
just six days time now the court will
look at whether the provisional
suspension should have been lifted it's
not even going to consider when the
medal ceremony for the team event can
take place so it could well be that
valeeva is not allowed to compete in her
individual event but could still end up
with a gold medal for the team event
after appeals and all the other legal
processes but at the heart of this let's
not forget that valeeva is just 15 years
old there's a duty of care over her but
it's not a good look for russia is it
the country has already been banned for
a doping scandal it's not even competing
under its real name here it's competing
under the russian olympic committee and
again more questions more controversy
surrounding russia and doping
that was jonathan crane there reporting
from beijing my first guest tonight is
the authority on doping in sports his
investigations have revealed
systemic cheating in cycling he also
reported on doping at the 2008 beijing
summer olympics i'm happy to welcome
sports journalist haiyo zeppel back to
the day hiyo it's good to see you again
and and let's be clear
about what could happen here vallieva's
next scheduled event is on february 15th
when she's favored to win gold in the
individual figure skating event if she
competes the world will know that this
15 year old on the ice has tested
positive for a banned substance
will this be a first
to be honest this is a very very very
sensitive case and a very very
complicated case um it's very clear and
obvious that she has been tested
positive for abandoned substance
on the other hand she's a minor athlete
she's 15 years old and this means
according to the rules it's quite
different to
adult athletes because it can happen
with children and we talk about children
here
that
she didn't know about what has been
found in her body that means third
parties have manipulated or have doped
her this makes it so complicated that
means if it comes to
get get a decision about if she's guilty
or not you have to consider that maybe
she didn't know about it that means in
at the very end that maybe she will not
be banned for four years or for two
years if this is all confirmed at the
very end
but what can happen next week is that
you will be suspended from the
competition because this is not fair
sport
apart from the question if he's guilty
or not
i mean it's it's actually is it's a
tragedy for her especially if she has
known nothing about
the doping
her trainers and coaches as you say
they're the ones responsible
i mean do you think this looks like
russian state-sponsored
doping the way we've seen it many times
before
that's what i cannot imagine um to be
honest because i think that
at least some of them have learned their
lessons after this big scandal but and
this is a news now for you um in berlin
we know that she is working together
with a doping doctor with a
guy
his name
is schwetzky philipp schwedski
and he is a kind of medical advisor and
he was already banned for doping because
he administered drugs to athletes 2007
and he's now working with her that means
at the very end she's very close to
dubious people also her coach
is is known as very hard is very rude
um and so
and as also
at least some people say that
i wouldn't say connected but maybe uh
not very far
from administering whatever kind of
medication that's what we heard in art
german televisions that means
she
that means camila valleva
might be a victim of her entourage
well i mean that's that's sobering and
that is definitely a new development
here
ohio
what do you think the international
olympic committee what should the
committee do now
that's what i said already um if it
comes to the competition next week it's
simply an unfair sport because you have
they have found a forbidden substance in
her
urine that means this is not a fair
competition and apart from the question
if she's guilty or not usually you
cannot say she will be allowed to
compete so
what i expect at the moment that is
really uncertain but i can imagine that
at the very end she will not be allowed
to compete but let's wait and see apart
from the question after the olympics
then they will open the b sample and
then the legal procedure will continue
do you think though that there should
have been a a better
vetting process of some sort because we
understand that she tested positive on
december 25th of last year and yet we
only found out about it after she
competed this week shouldn't something
have happened in between there to
prevent this performance from taking
place
you are totally right and i don't
understand it what happened it was
december 25th and it's a russian
championships in saint petersburg
and on february 8th the swedish
anti-doping lab which did the analyzing
of the sample
informed the russian anti-doping agency
one day after the team competition i
don't understand the delay it took
really long very long and it's what it
is overshadowed now the olympics it
would have been much better to do the
analyzers and to do the result
management before the games
yeah i think it's a good point i think a
lot of people are asking why it happened
the way it did hi yo zeppel it's always
good to see you we appreciate your
analysis tonight valuable insights thank
you
all the best take care